[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  have you been feeling have you been  sleeping any better Oh rough then you  can I never said well before hoes  condition condition that's cool  pregnancy it's okay to say you have loud  [Music]  some things happen can you just please  drive if you see some bad  [Applause]  what's going on people describe seen an  entity that takes on a form of U or  spheres  [Applause]  we can't stay here every contact we have  had with the outside has brought us  death here kids they deserve hope every  single decision I have made has been for  them  [Music]  listen to me  we're going on the trip now it's going  to be rough  if you hear something in the woods you  tell me  you hear something in the water you tell  me  under no circumstance are you allowed to  take off your blindfold  [Applause]  you  you